TAIWAN'S CONDEMNING CHINESE
SABER RATTLING, JUST OFF THE COAST AS
IRRATIONAL AND ACCUSING BEIJING
OF UNDERMINING REGIONAL PEACE.
CHINA FIGHT SEVERAL MISSILES
INTO THE WATERS OF TAIWAN TODAY
IN LIVE, A FIRE MILITARY
EXERCISES.
VIDEO POSTED ON WEIBO, SHOWS
ROCKETS BEING LAUNCHED FROM THE
COUNTY.
NOW ONE OF THE CLOSEST POINTS
ON THE MAINLAND TO TAIWAN, YOU
CAN SEE IT ON YOUR SCREEN.
CHINA'S LARGEST EVER DRAWLS IN
TAIWAN, COMING ONE DAY AFTER
U.S. SPEAKER, NANCY PELOSI PAID
A VISIT TO TAIWANESE OFFICIALS,
ANGER IN BEIJING AND SHE IS NOW
MOVED ON TO SOUTH KOREA AND
JAPAN.
THE AND FACT OF THE
CONTROVERSIAL STUFF IN TAIPEI
IS STILL BEING FELT AROUND
TAIWAN.
LET'S ALL GO LIVE TO BEIJING
RECENTLY, SELINA WANG IS
STANDING BY.
IT IS INCREDIBLE TO SEE THE
WRATH COMING THROUGH FROM THE
CHINESE MILITARY, AND
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW CLOSE
THEY ARE GETTING, WHAT DOES
THIS ACTUALLY MEAN?
THE SHOW FOR US BECAUSE WE HAD
ANTICIPATED THAT THEY WOULD
WANT TO SHOW STRENGTH, JUST NO
HARD TO WHAT EXTENT IT WOULD
MANIFEST.
>> WELL, LOOK THEM AS THE CHAIR
THAT BEIJING IS TRYING TO SEND
US THAT OUR POWERFUL MILITARY
HAS THE CAPABILITY TO
COMPLETELY CHOKE OFF OF TAIWAN
FROM THE WEST OF THE WORLD.
AND TO YOUR, POINT WE WERE
EXPECTING THE SHOW OF MUSCULAR
FORCE BECAUSE, CHINA NEEDED TO
LIVE UP TO THE EXTREME THREATS
THAT THEY WERE MAKING LEADING
UP TO THIS POINT.
BUT ONE OF THE BIGGEST ANTHRAX
POTENTIALLY OF THESE DRILLS, IT
IS GOING TO BE PSYCHOLOGICAL
AND INTIMIDATION.
IT IS SPARKING FEAR ABOUT WHAT
COULD COME, BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH
WE MAY NOT SEE THIS CURRENT
CRISIS ASKED GETTING INTO
SOMETHING MORE.
THIS PELOSI VISIT COULD
BASICALLY BE AN EXCUSE FOR
CHINA TO CHANGE THE STATUS QUO
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OVER
THE LONG RUN INTO MONTHS OR
YEARS TO COME INCREASING THE
COERCION OF TAIWAN EVEN MORE.
>>
MISSILES FIRING INTO THE SEA
OF TAIWAN.
FIGHTER JETS ARE SCRAMBLING TO
TAKE OFF.
AND PLUMES OF SMOKE SEEN BY
RESIDENTS IN THE CHINESE CITY
CLOSEST TO TAIWAN, THE VIDEO
SHOWS LIVE ROCKETS BEING FIRED
TOWARDS THE TAIWAN STREETS.
MOMENTS LATER, A STATE MEDIA
CONFIRMED THE LAUNCH.
THE WOMAN FILMING SAYS THAT,
WHILE WE ARE WITNESSING
HISTORY.
BEIJING UNLEASHING A SHOW OF
FORCE ON TAIWAN, OVER U.S.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI'S
VISIT TO THE ISLAND.
CHINESE MILITARY CLAIMS
STARTING THE LARGEST AVERAGE
ROLLS AROUND THE ISLAND.
>> MY TEAMMATES AND I FLEW IT
AND HEADED TO THE AIR SPACES
AROUND TAIWAN ISLAND.
WE ARE READY FOR COMBAT, ABLE
TO FIGHT WITH ANYTIME, DEFYING
BEIJING THREATS, PELOSI MET
WITH TAIWAN'S PRESIDENT, AND
KEY LAWMAKERS AND BUSINESS
LEADERS.
PROUD SUPPORTERS OF TAIPEI
WELCOMED HER.
>> TAIWAN'S BEEN AN ISLAND OF
RESILIENCE, AND NOW MORE THAN
EVER, AMERICA SOLIDARITY IS
CRUCIAL.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE THAT WE ARE
BRINGING HERE TODAY.
>> CHINA'S FOREIGN MINISTRY
SAYS THE TRIP IS A QUOTE,
OUTRIGHT FARCE.
TAIWAN CALLS THIS THE MEDIAN
LINE.
MORE THAN MORE THAN THAT --
THE DAY AFTER PELOSI LANDED,
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER.
>> THEY ARE DEMONSTRATED THAT
THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE TAIWAN'S
LINES, THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE
TAIWAN.
THIS IS AN ACT OF POLITICAL
WARFARE, PSYCHOLOGICAL WARFARE
AND INFORMATION WARFARE.
IT IS ALSO VERY IMPORTANT
SIGNAL TO CHINA'S OWN PEOPLE.
TO DEMONSTRATE ITS RESOLVE.
>> THESE BOXES IN CIRCLING THE
ISLAND ARE WHERE BEIJING SAYS
THE MILITARY DRILLS ARE
HAPPENING.
IT IS A BLOCKADE, IN BEIJING IN
TAIPEI.
AND A MAJOR PROVOCATION AND THE
EYES OF TAIWAN AND THE U.S..
BUT TO A LOT OF JOHNNY'S
EDITIONS, IT IS NOT ENOUGH.
ESPECIALLY AFTER OFFICIALS HAVE
HYPED UP EXPECTATIONS, OF AN
UNPRECEDENTED MILITARY
RESPONSE.
THIS APPOINTED, ROUTE ONE
PERSON ON CHINESE TWITTER LIKE
--
ANOTHER MOCKED THAT ITS LEADERS
SHOULD SPEAK LESS, DO MORE.
FAR FROM SPEAKING LESS,
OFFICIALS ARE ISSUING ONE FIERY
STATEMENT AFTER ANOTHER.
WHILE CONDEMNING THE TRIP.
ALSO BANNED IMPORTS OF
THOUSANDS OF FOOD ITEMS FROM
TAIWAN, AND SUSPENDED EXPORTS
OF NATURAL SAND.
A KEY COMPONENT AND
SEMICONDUCTOR CHIPS.
ALL OF THIS RAGE, JUST OVER A
TWO-DAY VISIT.
PELOSI'S PRESENCE IN TAIWAN, A
SLAP IN THE FACE TO BEIJING.
WHICH INSIST THE SELF GOVERNED
ISLAND IS A REBEL CHINESE
PROVINCE.
PELOSI IS OUT OF TAIWAN, BUT
SHE LEFT A CRISIS BEHIND HER.
BEIJING'S RETALIATION IS JUST
GETTING STARTED.
>> AS A RESULT OF THESE DRILLS,
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING TAIWAN
HAVING TO REROUTE SOME VESSELS,
AS WELL AS INTERNATIONAL
FLIGHTS.
IT HAS IMPACTED HUNDREDS OF
FLIGHTS, AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
BUSIEST WATERWAYS IN THE WORLD.
SO IT THREATENS TO UPEND GLOBAL
TRADE AS WELL, BUT WHEN WE LOOK
AT THIS STRONG REACTION FROM
CHINA, WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
IT IS ALSO DIRECTED AT THE
AUDIENCE HERE AT HOME.
BECAUSE XI JINPING, CHINESE
LEADER, NEEDS TO PROVE TO ITS
PEOPLE THAT THERE IS A PRICE TO
BE PAID FOR TAIWAN TO HOST
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI.
THERE IS A LOT OF PROPAGANDA
STRIKING IMAGERY AND
INFLAMMATORY LANGUAGE AROUND
THESE MILITARY DRILLS.
BUT WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO WATCH
IS HOW FAR CHINA ACTUALLY GOES
WITH THESE MILITARY DRILLS.
NOT HOW FAR STATE MEDIA CLAIMS
THEY WILL GO.
ELENI.
>> YES.
YOU ARE SAYING YOUR.
PEACE BEIJING'S RETALIATION IS
JUST GETTING STARTED.
THIS WAS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
WE HAVE BEEN ASKING IN THE LEAD
UP TO NANCY PELOSI'S TRIP.
IS THIS GOING TO BE A TURNING
POINT IN RELATIONS BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND CHINA?
AND CHINA AND TAIWAN?
IT SEEMS THAT THAT HAS BEEN A
TURNING POINT.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM SOME
OF THE ANALYSTS THAT YOU ARE
SPEAKING TO?
HOW FAR WILL TRY NOT TAKE THIS?
>> WELL, EXACTLY.
WE ARE ALREADY TODAY DECADES
LOW POINT IN THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND CHINA.
AND THIS IS JUST ADDING A
FURTHER FRICTION POINT.
AND THE CONCERN IS THAT WITH
ALL OF THE MISTRUST THERE IS
REALLY NO OFF RAMP FROM HERE.
WHEN IT COMES TO TAIWAN AND
CHINA, I WILL THESE MILITARY
ASSETS ON THE GROUND JUST
INCREASE THE RISK OF A
MISCALCULATION THAT COULD
SPIRAL INTO SOMETHING GREATER.
EVEN THOUGH CHINESE LEADER XI
JINPING DOES NOT WANT THIS TO
TURN INTO A DIRECT CONFLICT, IT
IS NOT IN CHINA'S BEST INTEREST
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
THIS STILL INCREASES THE RISK
THAT IT COULD.
WHEN I SPEAK TO SOME ANALYSTS,
THEY SAY, LOOK, THERE IS ALSO A
CONCERN THAT THIS PELOSI VISIT
GIVES CHINA AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRACTICE THESE SIMULATIONS,
LIKE WHAT THEY ARE CALLING A
SIMULATED BLOCKADE AGAINST
CHINA.
AN EXCUSE TO USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STEP UP ITS
DIPLOMATIC, POLITICAL, AND
ECONOMIC COERCION OF TAIWAN.
CHINA IS EXTREMELY INDIGNANT
OVER THIS, AND IN ORDER TO SAFE
PLACE FACE WITH THE PEOPLE AT
HOME AS WELL, THEY HAVE GOT TO
SHOW THIS STRONG MESSAGE, THE
STRONG REACTION, IT IS NOT
GOING TO LAST JUST A FEW DAYS.
THIS COULD HAVE RAMIFICATIONS
IN THE YEARS TO, COME ELENI.